pull up magnus stallion's foot you got
meg the stallion's footer no
who's troy lanes is he the one that
sings songs or is he a rapper
garage oh oh so she got shot in the foot
for realsies
so what's very interesting though what's
very interesting is that we're just
seeing this now and a lot of people
don't know meg the stallion or
uh troy lanes who are very prominent uh
who are very prominent
uh members of hip-hop big big stars in
the hip-hop community
and uh you know just shows you the way
the media covers
black domestic violence versus white
domestic violence because amber heard
and johnny depp
wearing the paper every day for you know
johnny depp taking his [ __ ] amber hurts
purse
and it's like little banal you know
benign [ __ ] but they're like oh my
god what a bad guy i'm toxic
and blah blah blah the media but then
actually a woman gets
shot by her boyfriend and
barely any coverage because the truth is
the media doesn't care about black
people kanye west was right
george bush and the media don't care
about black people
right they just pretend that they do but
they don't really pretend it's all
[ __ ] they pretend that's why
that's why the republicans sometimes
have good points when they say democrats
only care
they make believe that they care about
the blacks they get to vote it's kind of
when you see stories like this you're
like oh
they're probably not wrong you know well
you know what it is because they don't
they're
it's the political correct thing they
don't want to place a judgment
when the crime is black on black because
they're like who am i to say
so you gotta be i mean if her boyfriend
was white
make no mistake
that would probably be front page news
of the new york times
oh my god oh yeah they would [ __ ] say
what is this
what's going on the danger for black
women to date white guys
well it's the same thing it's the same
thing i know there's a lot of crimes in
the world but it's the same thing
you know a casio quartet you know when
that boy
the little the boy white boy was killed
by the black guy
uh shot in the head for no reason even
though i know the black man had uh some
schizophrenia or whatever but he's still
black man killed a white kid
they don't talk about that but aoc will
go on and be like a senator called me a
[ __ ]
and we need to talk about it but she
won't make a statement about the white
kid so that's just what it is
right you want to escape it all you want
but we're just calling the facts as we
see them
and it's just what it is and i just
think
uh you know and and that's something i
don't necessarily blame on the
good people i think that that's just a
symptom of
what this is and we're all pawns in
their little game so listen you do what
you want to do in november
i know what i'm doing what that doesn't
go to say that the other things that
they do make statements about
aren't bad or can't be bad it's just
it's so obvious
that both sides cherry-pick the ones
they're going to make statements on
because they support their narratives
and then thus doing so
they continue this division because they
just feed their base which is the lowest
common denominator of their followers
right and so it's not about the
principle it's about the interest
right and it's really their fault them
and the good guys
yeah them and the good guys yeah so what
can you do it's just
what it is go make sure you rate review
us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild